une défaite au goût amer pour montigny
le bretonneux après une entame de match
délicate les signé montait n'ont pas
réussi à s'imposer à domicile face à
tall carantec lors de la 16e journée du
championnat de nationale 2 score final
30 à 24 on a essayé de rectifier un peu
le tir à la mi temps on a demandé un peu
de compte quelques consignes
malheureusement elle n'a pas être n'ont
pas été respectées et l'équipe adverse a
su justement jouer sur nos points
faibles
voilà donc on est là il voulait pas
qu'on revienne j'étais d'ailleurs sur le
plan psychologique que nous ont laissé
justement le score et ça c'est très très
on va dire c'est très dur pour repos
pour les filles en fait françois on
s'est battu jusqu'à la fin c'est le
sentiment qu'il va falloir retenir quand
même monté une remontée sur la fin donc
ça nous a permis de garder l'espoir
jusqu'au bout de garder les coeurs des
supporters jusqu'au bout qui virevoltait
un petit peu mais
décès sont principalement avec cette
défaite les féminines de montigny le
bretonneux sont désormais 8e avec un
bilan de 6 victoires 1 nuls et 9
défaites en 16 matches disputés chaque
match est important étant donné notre
position c'est à dire que nous sommes
classés dans la 2ème partie du
classement notre objectif c'est de
remonter sur la première partie puisque
c'est toujours mieux d'être en sécurité
va se battre jusqu'au bout pour le
maintien donc c'est très dur c'est une
poule très de danse bur tout le monde
peut battre tout le monde
dreux la semaine dernière un malheur il
on a été les chercher la victoire à
taulé et cette semaine ils viennent
gagner ici donc voilà c'est un peu de
vent prochaine rencontre pour les
inhumant tel le samedi 19 mars à
domicile face à lanester un autre gros
morceau l'équipe est classée 5e du
championnat